A CLEARING TRY
FROM MAR ZONE.  RETURN PASS,
AN ABSOLUTELY CRACKLING SWAT
SHOT THAT BEATS CAL PETERSEN ANN
TO BE SQUARED.
>> WE KNOW HOW BIG BODY, NOT BY
PUCK.
DIDN'T GET THEHE WHISTLED DOWN.
>> SO TREVOR MOORE WITH
KOPITAR OFF THE BENCH AND ONE
AGAINST IN KINGS FRANCHISE
HISTORY, THE BY
DENAULT OFF THE
THE PERIMETER, YOU DON'T OFTEN R
THIS FAR
FAKING THE SLAP SHOT.
DENAULT, PASS DOESN'T GET
THROUGH, DIRECT ON THAT LAST PA.
IN FRONT OF LIZOTTE. VEGAS
IS GETTING IT COUNTER AWAY?
MARCHESSAULT.
OVER THE KINGS LINE.
STRIPPED BY IAFALLO.
TR WAY.
WATCH IAFALLO, BACK CHECK, BACK
PRESSURE, STRIP, AND THE PUCK.
AND LOBS IT SITUATION.
IN THAT CIRCUMSTANCE, I
THINGS AWAY.
YOU NEED TWO UNITS WORKING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
>> KOPITAR WINS A WORK.
WIN THE FACE-OFF, MOVE THE PUCK
AROUND, GET US IN MIDDLE
KARLSSON IN THE BACK.
>> KOPITAR TAKES THE
>> THAT WAS IT RIGHT THERE.KE TT
MOVE.
AS SOON AS HE GOT IT THE CUT
BACK, WATCH THIS.
MARTINEZ WITH THE PUCK HERE. PU.
TRIED TO PAW IT DOWN AFTER IT
POPPED OFF HIS